each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon everyone my name is Kim
rickets and I manage the visiting
speaker series for Microsoft Research
thanks for coming on this beautiful day
I'd like to introduce kencana our
speaker today to you he is here all the
way from did you come all the way from
Oxford just for one day Indiana no I'm
I'm here for the month in Palo Alto
can't come one day yeah and then you're
going back down tonight ken has worked
on this kind of a project in many ways
for over 30 years he um it's culminated
in in a website and a patented product
that he has called tuned top which is a
state-of-the-art programming language
video game for children I'll let him
explain it to you but I think we're all
quite fascinated on how we engage
non-programmers non-engineers in in you
know the dialogue of the kind of things
that we create here and research at
Microsoft so that's why we invited Kim
here I'm thrilled to have him here we'll
do a question and answer at the end so
kenko how much time should i would say
speak for about 30 minutes okay okay
great good well thanks for coming so let
me show you the was planning to talk
about so one of the ideas so I can just
mention tune talk and that's been sort
of my main activity for for quite a
while but in the last two or three years
it's kind of created led to some two or
three other projects that I want to talk
about briefly and the theme that ties it
all together is that even though tune
talk is designed such that even very
young children could can build programs
from the bottom up one of the things we
kind of discovered is especially through
some research projects that were
building on tune talk that's what the
playground and web labs is about is that
a lot of the actions happening one level
above the raw code where the you're
giving the the children or the students
pre-built pieces that are carefully
designed to be easy to compose easy to
inspect or edit
and they're not what I even have a
little slide here supposed to show it so
that I think of them as as autonomous
little processes that can be
hierarchically composed and that which
what people normally mean by components
things like modules or classes or
procedures or something and one of the
things you'll see in a second is how
often you can just stick them together
without worrying at all about how they
interface but sometimes you do a bit
more so so those are the the four
systems i want to show wouldn't will be
kind of a quick thing and then what I
also want to but I'm going to show them
with the theme of of how you could do
this kind of some people call it middle
out programming were you kind of
composing things Google upward and then
you may be inspecting customizing
editing a little bit to go downward from
the middle and but as I show these
systems I wanted to kind of make clear
their other sort of big ideas underlying
these these different systems i'll be
showing so tune talk the original
conception of it wasn't so much this one
of this higher level composing of
components but it was this idea of what
i call concretization so that all the
computational abstractions about
conditionals or communications or
processes are all that are given
concrete playful analogues of things
like trucks and birds and houses and
bombs and things another aspect to talk
is your programming very concretely with
examples and then later saying it's how
you want it to be more general and the
other thing that was that rather than
have any kind of standard interface that
one might have for a visual programming
language to get the interface borrow
heavily from runway games work and
playground is this European research
project went for three years in which
we're working mostly with six seven
eight year olds trying to help them and
give them tools to build their own
computer games and part of the
additional idea under that one is the
idea that the way in which they could
the children even in cross you know
Sweden England
something could communicate was using
these communication facilities within
tune talk that enabled you not just to
send messages but to send running
programs back and forth and maybe I'll
have a little give you a little sense of
what that was like and web labs followed
up from playground saying working with
older children 11 to 14 year olds and
they're the focus was much more on
learning science and math but via
programming so the children would be
building models of a food web or
bouncing balls or of a lunar lander kind
of thing or they'd be exploring
mathematics and one of the things that
was particularly kind of well suited for
doing that was the fact that Thun talk
uses one of these exact arithmetic
packages that so there's never any round
off you could have millions of digits of
accuracy using rational numbers
underneath so that was all the tune talk
related kinds of things and then the BBC
launched this big five year 300 million
dollar project that unfortunately failed
after two years or something but call
originally was called the digital
curriculum project and then it was
launched as something called jam so that
little kids could remember the name and
we were asked to kind of build some
proof of concept things of how much
further they could go with with this
website in which the slogan was create
learned players so I wanted to briefly
show you some of those things though
again maybe we'll see how time goes and
and then I got about part time in this
in another European project that's
called re math and the part of it that I
was involved in we built this system
called mo pics and mo pics is yet
another system of which you could build
your programs by composing these pieces
and so on but the really unusual thing
is that instead of a programming
language underlying it you just have
algebraic equations so it's particularly
suited for
for say high school algebra or high
school physics ocean and then the the
latest thing that I've been working on
it at most of these things have been at
the London knowledge lab which is part
of the university of london but i also
have a part-time position at Oxford
where have been doing try and take these
same ideas and ask well what would they
be at the university level and have a
system called the behavior composer
which hopefully all have time to show
and then we just got funded for a
follow-up project that's called modeling
for all that takes the same ideas but
adds web 2.0 and some Second Life ideas
okay because I am kind of rushing
because here all right great um no
either ways fine okay yeah so okay so
maybe after all that we should start
some of the demos or something so start
with tune talk
so there's lots of things to say about
just this opening screen I'm using
Microsoft agent here to sort of it's
very hard to give a demo he keeps
talking so I'm going to send him away or
something but part of the idea was to
really make a programming language that
that worked from very small children all
the way up to university level students
and we actually succeeded in the sense
that there were various universities
that have used it even for courses in
concurrent algorithms at the same time I
had a I worked with this doctoral
student in Portugal who was exploring
what could preschoolers do with tune
talk and but but one of the issues is
that if you're trying to reach small
children lots of stuff to read could
become a big obstacle so it's important
to kind of integrate text to speech and
agents and so on Thompson so what I when
I first started to talk i had this naive
idea that you just build a programming
system in which people could build
programs and that's that then everything
will be fine and discovered pretty early
on that you need to produce all sorts of
surrounding material yeah text to speech
doesn't bore you to tears is difficult
yes yes right right yes now that's a
good point and it's and I majority of
the children do send the speaking
characters away one of the things that
one solution for that for in some
contexts like here I'll show you a
little introductory tour of a tune talk
maybe I should minimize this man is
coming up and what what's going on here
is we actually have voice actors I know
remember if this is the UK or the US
version I've installed here but the
second wasn't here yeah this is the UK
version
I packed and I'll be happy to show you
around if I hold down the right mouse
button we fly off so that is much more
interesting than the synthetic speech
but of course you can't it's not as
flexible it has to be only for canned
speech and one of the things that into
talks going on is that there's the need
to not only you compose sentences and
speak them and then you do have the
problem that the that a lot of people
don't like listening to it but rather
than let this demo continue oh maybe
I'll just one of the things that's cute
about this is that isn't just a playback
of a video you actually is playing back
the system and if I click on this button
now we kind of jump live into this
context hopefully
it says I'm waiting tweeting or
something yeah
mm-hmm should be I don't know oh here
comes so just being in paper back to to
talk I was just being impatient sorry
anyway so here we are I'm just taking
over
no someone we lost the audio though
maybe I'll restarted sorry I don't know
what's me
all right we'll jump into free play and
in free play wow so i'll say i don't
know ms are so it's gone I can't tie
anything anyways maybe we'll look like
this okay so here we are so the idea is
that we're in this very plain empty City
nothing going on in this their Island an
island itself is very impoverished but
when you got out you followed by this
toolbox if you walk into a house used to
be that Marty would just greet you and
start talking to you again a lot of
people didn't like him talking to you so
now he kind of indicates that he push f1
he'll come in and help you and say the
market here I'll stay long to help you
if i bother you just push the s-1 button
and i'll go if i go then f1 we call me
back so most kids pushing everyone at
this acquaintance is get rid of it but
some of them really and one of the
lessons behind that is that there really
isn't a one-size-fits-all that some kids
really do like to have Marty around
helping some of them don't someone like
them talking some of them will want to
jump into this puzzle tutorial game that
I don't probably don't have time to show
you some of them want to sit there and
watch the demos there's a lot of
different ways of interacting with the
system so when you sit down you have all
the building blocks of your programs
here in the toolbox and you have some
tools you could use and you've a
notebook of various things so maybe I'll
show you really quickly this simple very
simple quick example but then I want to
jump up to the level at which most of
the children in playground were
interacting with the system which show
you that missing
so one of the first simple examples that
and again really kind of Russians
because I want to cover so many other
things is suppose we want to have a
robot that will just keep doubling a
number so first off the way we double
numbers you pick up the magic wand make
a copy and if you drop a number on a
number bamber the mouse smashes them
together like this and and we can keep
doing this over and over again but when
to be nice to have a robot do it for us
because they like doing repetitive rings
so when I give the a box to a robot we
enter into his imagination Marty's here
to help us or who don't know what was
going on offering to help us and all we
want to do is have now instead of
controlling the arm we're controlling
the robot but its exact same kind of
actions you know what I'm going to have
a mouse pad here because somehow when I
move the mouse it's not not always
moving so so if we pick up the wand copy
this and drop it just like we were doing
kind of in the freeplay environment
world indicate that we're done training
then we've taught the robot how to copy
copy the number four and drop it on top
to make eight but obviously that's a
pretty limited program so he does that
and then he looks at the box again and
it it's a box with an eight and he only
knows how to deal with four but we know
that it doesn't matter what number is in
there so what we could do is use this
tool and make this program much more
general now we're saying if if the
robots thinking about a box with any
number in it then he'll do what he was
trained to do and then once he's done
training doing what he was trained to do
he looks at the box again and says does
it still match so oh you implicitly have
iteration and obviously if you set
things up so that stops matching at some
point you can
it terminate or something and there's
one of the tools called pumpy all these
have funny names dusty and Pompey and
bammer is this will make things change
the size of things you could sort of see
better what's happening or something if
I stand up the robot will keep working
on the floor even though the faster or
simple but if I just walk outside even
for a second and come back then it's
about to warn us maybe I'll just ignore
this right now it's warning us that that
because our numbers have gotten so big
don't be worried if things take a little
bit of time or something and what's
happened is that it was able to double
this number huge number of times in that
brief moment we were outside so it would
stop the robot years so here we have
this number and if we wanted to get a
sense of what this number is we could
kind of move it around and it just keeps
going and going on so one idea that's
explored a bit in the web labs project
with just this idea of numbers just
integers was if you take it outside and
set it down in the grass and then if you
stand up you can see it's the numbers
right there now we can go for a walk and
see how big our number is or something
and keep walking and walking and you get
kind of tired so we'll call for the
helicopter and
now we'll go fly
and well we didn't actually make it big
enough as big as the city it seems as if
we got one that's almost a mile long or
something but if we let it run for a
couple more seconds I could assure you
with sticking out into the water been a
very big number and one of the things
that's kind of fun is you could there
besides numbers there's these other data
types like like text and things for
communication for comparison for Sonic
starting new processes and then a
notebook with all sorts of gadgets in it
and one of the things in here is a text
to speech gadget tortoise and if I the
first off you could just have it
speaking to each and I could type to it
you know say text to what whatever
you know you could have a text well
whatever but if we erase it then what
we're saying is we want to convert
whatever we drop onto it into a text the
speech thing so take this number and
here we've converted it into um to Quinn
Septuagint or a million 374 crafts so
Septuagint 23 million 360 to dress up
George in several million 775 do except
sewage into three million it could go on
for garage into a very long time 800m
it's very one of the things for getting
a sense of what big numbers are all
about is to ask the question you know
well how long would it take to say that
whole number and what you can do is like
copy and paste it into text buffer and
see that it's how long it is and then
just see how long it takes this how far
you get through it in 60 seconds and one
number we were working with worked out
to three weeks before we finish saying
the number of something so you can make
very big numbers you could also make
very small numbers we could take one and
divide it by this number so now we're
going to one over that ridiculously big
thing but of course it's going to an
awful lot of zeros as a matter of fact
if we fly to the other and we ought to
see something different but it should be
zeros for quite a long time
no it still serves well we'd have to go
even further and probably not the time
to do it so this is sort of a quick
sample of kind of what it's like at the
at the bottom up level but what I wanted
to talk about with more was about the
component level and so one of the things
that they did in the playground project
this was the project to help six to
eight year olds build games hi Mikey we
could be bald this time is they built
this city with in tune talk where
they'll be areas where there's all sorts
of components for building games there's
areas whereas clip art or clip sound
effects or and there's also areas where
there's a lot of pre-built games and
what I wanted to show is give you a
sense of what some seven-year-olds kind
of did so here's these neighborhoods
this is where you've got gadgets for
moving or changing appearance or making
sounds or reacting to events here you've
got clipart clip sounds and here there's
a lot of built games pre-built games so
here we have a little pong game I just
grab a copy of it and set it down
somewhere and I could just play it I
could hide my hand or something can move
the other moment should be sounded and I
can make it over bigger so we see it
better or something so that's okay but
you know game like that these days in
about a minute and you're tired of it
but the interesting thing is that it's
completely malleable so for example I
could take the magic wand and copy a
ball and start it up again now I have
two balls in our in my game and they
bounce off each other and everything if
I was curious about how everything
worked
then I could say take one of these take
it off or take a copy doesn't really
matter and then I could flip it over and
here's where the components kind of come
when I'm gonna he's pumping to make this
bigger so there's three um behaviors and
each one is composed out of smaller ones
so here's one behavior that we can look
at UM make this bigger so this is the
behavior that just gives it an initial
movement horizontally and vertically in
the two are being composed and at the
bottom of all this you finally get down
to a a box that's being given to a robot
and any of these things could be kind of
explored on our own if you want to see
what moving to the right does on its own
i could just take it i'll flip it over
even has a kind of a nice appearance
turn it on and sure enough it goes to
the right or something and this one if I
if I put it back together again flip it
over it'll um but here's the but here's
the important back
I think is that these things could be
combined I could take the moving upward
behavior drop it on this thing I could
take the moving to the right behavior
drop it here take this object whatever
it is just a square and when I turn it
on sure enough it does both so you could
not only kind of compose things at this
level so let me tell you to two stories
I'll tell you one story and then show
you the other one one story is 27 year
old girls in London they started taking
this game and they started just
initially just fiddling with the
background color and when it was blue
one of them said oh it's water why do we
have a game about fish so one of them
looked around in here and found some oh
maybe I'll give you the first part of
the string so they found some picture of
a fish in a notebook and they just flip
the fish over doesn't have any behavior
just artwork but that you could get down
here where our game is or something we
could take off one of these balls spit
it out flip it over and all those
behaviors so you don't even at this
point even care about what all they're
doing about bouncing and starting to
move and son and just give them all to
the fish so now when I drop the fish
onto this maybe I'll clean up a little
bit now when I turned it on we've got a
bouncing fish so they ended up adding
they thought the fish was lonely and
they added like five or 10 fish while
bouncing around and they thought it was
silly that the fish were bouncing off
paddles they changed the paddle into a
shark and then they said but wait a
minute that the petition be bouncing of
a shark the shark should actually eat it
so then they had to go to the down into
programming to change that behavior so
that's one kind of story from playground
of 27 year old girls in England
but the story I wanted to show you in a
bit more detail is these 27 year old
boys in Sweden and they had taken the
pong game and they'd also played this
real simple little space invaders game
you make it bigger so you're this maybe
I move my hand you could shoot anyways
this or something and they had this idea
they were going to make space pong so
what they did was they took the pong
game probably made it a bit bigger and
the first thing they did was said let's
just copy the invaders into the pong
game so it picked up the magic wand
copied this and copied this somewhere
and maybe even two of them or something
maybe the third invader terrific so so
now if we play this we have our bouncing
ball and it bounces off the invaders and
there's all these funny sounds but but
it's not they realized that they wanted
something more that had both in space
invaders in pawn combined so what they
did was they they removed the the ship
from from the space invaders game
flipped it over and there's all these
behaviors here and they actually spent a
lot of time seeing what each one did and
playing with them and stuff but we're
going to be quicker than that because
well all I want to do is find the one
that will shoot there's even once for
joysticks mass but I think
this one says I fire in four directions
and they only wanted to fire in one
direction and this one is probably the
right one I fire white both upwards when
you press the uparrow key okay so what
they did was they remove the paddle what
oh I got the wrong no the I got the fish
game thank you somewhere I could stand
up maybe well maybe I will have to stand
up I don't know oh there it is thank you
okay so what they did was they remove
the paddle flipped it over it's got
these behaviors for being a paddle and
then they just combined it this combined
with it just this one behavior of
shooting vertically and added this to
the game and then they could not only my
hand here when I play the game but we
could shoot mittens and this bullets
would actually blow up invaders who want
to blow up the I think it blows up for
them maybe as you play maybe you get the
idea that you can combine the behaviors
of these games at this level of
components rather than having to always
dig down to the level of robots and
boxes and birds and so on so maybe I'll
show you some other examples of things
there's of course a lot more you can do
it to talk one thing i should say me
before we leave Tim talk here is that
you could grab this hit a pause button
and you could turn it into a Java applet
add it to the project website all sorts
of things so they're made it very easy
for kids not just to create these things
but especially in the web labs project
to share them and then have the objects
right there in the discussion page or in
the email for the other kids to maybe
try out and comment down or improve or
something actually one more one more
last thing before i forget the because i
mentioned another idea that was behind
the playground project was the way in
which that you do communication so
there's this communication mechanism
within tune talk that's based on the
idea of kind of them I metaphor if I
homing pigeons so if I give a bird
anything like this word pictures she
picks it up takes it to her nest and
comes back but I could actually take
this bird put it on the clipboard paste
it into a message send it to Sweden some
kid there could paste copy and paste the
bird into tune talk and then if they had
this game that they really like they
could give it to the bird and it'll just
appear in London if they kids kids nest
so that was a way in which they could
exchange things in a way that was fit
very well the sort of world they already
knew never had to leave the world in
order to exchange it's underneath this
word pictures and of course they could
also say you know ah just hit the wrong
button hit the pause button you know uh
what do you think about you know my game
or something and give that to the bird
and then we'll fly off to the other
country and so did they get up
conversations the swype and I was even
working with a bunch of ten-year-olds in
England who I've been working with four
of them and they really knew tune talk
well but the rest of the class never got
a chance so we had a one day with were
the four kids were going to show the
other kids what you could do in tune
talk and what they did was they they got
all the computers they too they made a
very complicated communication network
with lots of birds and nests and started
broadcasting and sending messages all
around and they really were able to sort
of rewire the whole thing because one of
the things that's going on here is this
is all sort of kind of first class
objects that if I have vomited in Sweden
and I suddenly have a nest that I want
some kid to be able to send messages to
I could put the bird or a copy of the
bird into a box and send that to the
other kid so now that other kid now has
a way to communicate back with me of a
way to kind of rewire your whole
communication structure and was fun was
to see 10 or 12 10 year-olds just going
wild with this thing of course then they
started sending messages like you know
somebody's got bad breath there you
stinkers you know but it was the
interesting the way they were mastering
the communication primitives here and
able to set up a network okay so we move
on to yeah this is a there's a really
interesting idea inside of this one
fortunately it takes a minute to load so
but so this is this was done in the
context of the of this BBC project now
so this is meant to be kind of a very
interdisciplinary very educational but
very web oriented so it might be used in
schools when it might be just some kid
at home who comes across this website
and this is not the polished kind of
production value stuff that they had on
their website those you know across many
millions of pounds this is a proof of
concept kind of software but the the big
big new idea in it okay so me show you
this
is well this was just meant to be the
screen that you might run across the
that would encourage you to go further
here's what you might be able to do
build a lunar lander came with this
astronaut game and it'll be fun but
it'll be kind of hard but you'll have
people help you'll have virtual
characters helping you and so on so
because this was just done this
proof-of-concept we didn't have an
artist but we had two of the kids in the
project volunteered to make all the
artwork so you could click kid ones
artwork or kid tues artwork or something
but the important big idea here is that
this was a vision of a game for making
games so it's a it's a game in which the
player as it says right here it's your
first day at the game development
company and you're you're in charge of
building some games so here's the
director of the company telling you well
let's start with really simple game of
just an astronaut in space and has to
get back to the ship and you know don't
worry you don't know how to do anything
because I've assigned a whole team to
help you or something so here's the team
so you have the the programmer who if
you go to her right now I think she'll
say great idea but I don't know what to
do because but you better find you know
you can have to talk to others about
what to do so we could go back you know
if we go to the scientist the scientist
will maybe say you know got some ideas
but maybe you're going to have to go to
the game designer the assistant game
designer to get some ideas how this is
going to fit inside of a game and you go
back and forth like this collecting
various suggestions ideas but also
eventually kind of resources so
eventually the programmer will give you
some some equations then you can go back
to the program or the programmer says
okay great I understood that here's some
code and oh so the other thing was big
you know the idea if you can make this
sort of
a playful game is not just to have sort
of stick to the task but to kind of have
characters a little different senses of
humor or different care you know so one
guy is always getting spitting out
poetry which I just sort of googled for
space poetry or something and it turns
out some famous poets did write some
poems about traveling in space but here
was just a cute thing which was the fact
that the England's first astronaut was
from Mars because her job was at the
Mars chocolate factory so and if you
clicked on this and we have the internet
connection you'd actually go to the BBC
history page and learn more about her if
you're interested see the whole idea of
you this should be a good experience
even if you got five minutes but if you
if you got a few hours you could really
go kind of deep and there's there's more
but again I wanted to give you a sense
if we say let's make the game we haven't
really gone through the gate the
metagame far enough that we really got
the resources or know what we're doing
but as part of the demo I'm going to say
I want to go ahead anyways and
unfortunately we're well big enough for
this demo normally when you start up
this thing you could either go straight
into the game making then you get the
full fledged game making thing with all
sorts of features or if you stick if you
started going through the game then you
get this kind of a very simple kind of
few building blocks and you have to go
back and talk to more people and get a
few more things get back so I think
we're in the mode where there's just a
couple gadgets but maybe i'll still give
you a sense of what so this isn't built
on tune death built actually built on a
version of logo and this is analogous to
those animal gets that we saw in
playground do i don't know if i called
amana gadgets thing so so this one is
sitting there built out of this one
piece of code here's a bunch of comments
here's the code the red parts are parts
that you should feel free to change even
if you don't know what you're doing and
the other things you should probably
know what you're doing or some
but you don't have to go this deep so
one of the concepts underlying this is
what we call layered learning so that
you could you could go very far without
ever looking at a bit of code but if you
wanted to kind of have more control or
kind of learn about the programming but
once you have a gadget like this you
could just drop it on something like
this and now it's got the ability to
move horizontally or something and maybe
we'll give it an initial velocity so now
it's got these two behaviors on the back
so now if I say start the game there
goes not very exciting game yet but you
eventually there's quite a lot of good
physics going on in here in terms of
conservation of momentum and Newton's
laws and all these kinds of things and
and there's even a version oh you know
the button but where you could have a
two-player version so you could play
that where another kid could be another
computer on the same network can be
playing the game and what's funny is
that in this case the whole concept of
the game was this sort of rescue thing
where one player could be controlling
the lunar lander and the other one the
astronaut and and you're both trying to
the Landers astronauts trying to get
back and the pilot and the Landers
trying to rescue the and you know it's a
cooperative game and it was all fine
tested and then of course the first time
we tried her out with some thirteen year
olds they decided that that's the wrong
game design they wanted they built their
game so that the astronauts trying to
get back and the pilots trying to get
away from them to just kill a them
behind yes they had the very different
concept of what the game should be and
one of the cute things too was when you
were switched from this game to the
lunar lander kind of game that many of
the same building blocks applied that
you could sort of see the commonality of
the physical processes and computational
processes and also for any of these
objects if you flip them over you could
get help from any of those six different
characters about that object either
about the behavior or the OP
or you can click on settings so that the
idea was that you could like what does
it say I don't know change the mass of
the lander so here you could you know
just get a slider for just making this
change so you don't have to even touch
the code as in the previous things but
you had this little slider and then you
can even kind of use this same strange i
guess it was NASA head of heavier item
the numbers but you could even have the
historically accurate one so this was
another experiment that's building on
the same idea of the sort of middle out
programming were you you're not
expecting them to learn start with to
learn logo programming and what
variables or conditionals or procedures
are all about instead they're kind of
grabbing these gadgets and composing
them and parameterizing them and also
adding other things to their user
interface various kinds of graphs and so
on so let me move on I think probably
best okay so Moe pics is still all these
zombie talking about our kind of past
tense but no pics is like the middle of
this project and this time it's
implemented in flash which is very nice
in the sense that you could go to the
website and just play it without having
to install anything which is getting to
be increasingly important in schools
least in in the UK that even teachers
aren't really allowed to install things
on the school computers without a huge
lengthy bureaucratic process so what we
have here is just like before you kind
of pull out an object and the object
doesn't have any behaviors on it doesn't
have any properties but we could sort of
take instead of dropping little bits of
code on it we're going to drop little
bits of equations on it so here's an
equation that sets the initial vertical
I mean the horizontal velocity and would
just give it to the
thing and here's one that actually
defines what it means to be under what I
could do about there's probably some
zoom thing ya know zoom zoom in right
now there we go so the me here is just
the object that you're going to attach
this to so when you drop it on its going
to become object one or something
instead of me everywhere and it's just
saying that the exposition at some time
is just its previous exposition plus its
velocity at the current time so let's
get back to this
so we could keep adding more and more
equations to our objects here's one for
acceleration here's defining velocity we
could even have things predicates that
we add to it for like bouncing or
something so now we have should have
something that moves to the wall and
then should bounce off it when it gets
there but the important thing is that
that this becomes a tool for not just
sort of computational things but also
for learning about algebra or physics
and just to kind of give you if I had a
web connection I could be able to go to
the to the website where you could save
and restore models but actually I have
yeah I think well I'll find it there is
I have a model that I think I I'll find
it pretty quickly
so again this is only because they don't
have a web connection so here's the the
representation of this model in math ml
which is a kind of XML and if I go back
to our our tool here and I say xml this
is the XML of what we just built but if
I if I replace it by the new thing
but something happened here
it's not coming oh here we go so this
was something one of the students built
we just had two balls that bounce and
then the black square was defined to
always be at the average position of the
two balls and also to leave behind this
kind of colorful trail and she was doing
this kind of just playfully but it's
pretty interesting from the point of
view of kind of map education because
there's a lot of things that are
interesting like why does why does it
kind of go vertical up and down for a
while here it's going to go do it again
and other times it's moving horizontally
what's going on there and the it's
interesting to kind of have students
play with this and try to figure it out
generally the Muslim figure out that
that if the two balls are moving apart
at the same speed than the average is
going to be no motion and that's why
it's moving vertically so when the both
balls are moving left or both moving
right then the square moves left or
right but otherwise if they're moving in
opposite directions it just was written
so that one is developing we're in the
process of building a sort of a more of
a web-based Ajax kind of version of this
so that's it's even more feature phul
and flexible and stuff but again the
really surprising thing is how far you
can get with just equations and not any
kind of imperative programming there and
there is also a whole editor here for
building equations but I don't really
have time to show that or something
later okay I'm almost done with demos
so here's yet another version of the
same idea of kind of providing these
chunks of code that were easy to compose
but this time it's at the level of
university students are and it turns out
even researchers are have been
interested in this and there's a couple
new ideas in this one as well so the the
one one of the new ideas that's really
worked out quite well is this whole
bottom area here is an ordinary browser
and this is whole thing is sort of a
java application that that puts to get
helps you put together these programs
and then runs them with yet another tool
and if we say that we want to browse for
behaviors there's all sorts of behaviors
that are sitting there on this website
which happens to be a wiki and there's
ones for movement and appearance and
reproduction eating and there's also a
whole bunch of them for that are
reconstructions in a very modular way of
models that have been published and
often by people that were working with
it at Oxford so maybe I'll show you the
basic idea first and then I'll show you
sort of a neat model in a second so if i
click on move forward on this web page
here we have a little summary of what it
does the code itself sitting here a
button that if we click it will add it
to an object in this case we need to
give it a name such as called prototype
one a description of how you can make
variants of it related behaviors but
even with this simple model just one of
two objects one of which has a behavior
than one doesn't I could say run it in
what's constructing in this case very
trivially putting that one thing
together into a program to run in this
other tool that's from Northwestern
University that's a very popular
modeling tool for both beginners and for
people another field so here we see the
object prototype one moving forward this
one not moving at all so again just like
with you saw even with the Tim talk one
if we you can come SART combining these
things
so like a related behavior is one that
will turn randomly a little bit to the
left or right so if we add this to the
prototype and we say run my model and I
click go now we see it's kind of moving
like this and it's trying to keep a
constant speed I do this it'll just run
as fastest as it can or something but
but for if you're trimming simulation
you often want everything to have a
constant relationship between simulation
time and real time so let me show you a
more serious model here so if I go back
to the brows so i'll show you the
vaccination one so we're working with
Professor mathematical biology at oxford
who has written papers of modeling
diseases and vaccine policies and stuff
and we kind of took it and we mapped it
in 20 hopefully we'll find it yeah maybe
there's this question of whether it
should have this should be a local copy
of it but maybe doesn't I don't know
what's happening because the problem
again is that I don't have an internet
connection so it's trying to use this
local cache doesn't seem to be finding
but i'll show you another model that's
interesting that i know is sitting here
on the on this machine sorry
what's going on
um
so here this is one that we've worked
with with the business school at Oxford
so we've had MBAs and some other masters
students who are never in their lives
going to need to build computer models
but the professor involved understood
the value what he called modeling
literacy that the idea that students
should at least have some understanding
of what limitations the possibilities of
modeling because they're going to be
probably interacting with people and
relying on computer models so here's one
that's based on this book called growing
artificial societies and you can see
there's quite a lot of behaviors that
have been added to the to each agent and
the environment and some other ones and
if I just click on run my model we could
see how it how it runs so here we've got
a bunch of agents all starting off in
the corner here and the yellow or areas
are where there's more food or resources
and some of them have different
abilities in terms of how far they could
see or have much energy they consume or
money they consume and then here we're
actually doing this thing that's kind of
a Lawrence curve which is just showing
the way in which wealth is distributed
in this community or this society so the
straight line would be if everybody was
had equal amount of wealth and you can
see that as this is evolving there's
gets to be more and more inequalities
just by the very kind of basic nature of
this society or something and it's also
producing various graphs and stuff down
here so you could make it Explorer kind
of different models and also what was
very good pedagogically was that we had
them build this model in like 15 or 16
smaller steps so they would take a step
and just run it even though it was just
one object moving around a really simple
world then they would add another step
where the world would have a little bit
more and then they'd have more objects
and then they introduced life and death
or various kinds of things so each time
they were kind of get a sense more of
what was going on
because they were building it in a
step-by-step process and we have other
ones working with in zoology with
schooling fish I mentioned the epidemic
one there's I don't a few more of these
kinds of models that we're doing and
then I mentioned that where we're going
next is this other this new project
that's going to try to create a website
in which is much easier for everybody to
build these kinds of tools but also to
share that the models the micro
behaviors also be able to tag and rate
each other's work discuss them sort of
all the advantages you get from kind of
a social online network like that to it
but in this case instead of being like
for Flickr for photos it's our software
for computer modeling and then we had
the idea that that these same micro
behaviors can be implemented both in our
system and also in second life such that
you build a model of house fish school
and then you could import it into second
life and experience a kind of first hand
by seeing the fish not only first person
point of view but you can even be a fish
or ride efficiency would it be like and
see how much you could influence it so I
think at the end here so
yeah okay
what okay in terms of studying how
people clearly a large part is watching
what people there
is that one of the creation story yeah
so there's a couple dimensions as one is
the sort of the one that's sort of
informs the software design and the
other one is is all the research in
terms of what are people actually
learning from it so one point of view is
that doesn't much matter this is just a
tool for being creative and expressing
yourself and we all are pretty sure
they're learning great stuff but we
don't have to kind of demonstrate that
or the other thing is to show you know
that as result of using the software's
the children understand Newton's laws
better than some other group or
something so so for the latter question
like within the web labs project
different partners had very different
approaches so like in Cyprus they really
did take this approach of pre-tests and
post-tests and getting over 100 students
and careful measurements of what was
going on while in and Sweden and in
England they were much more of you know
carefully analyzing a ten-minute little
video segment of what two kids were
doing and kind of looking at it in fine
detail and then drawing conclusions
about how how much they must have
understood in order to be able to do
this or say this or how they were using
the software to refer to concepts that
are normally very abstract but they
could just point to them in this case so
and then in terms of the software it's
it really has been more of the sort of
informal process of having all different
kinds of testers all different kinds of
Ages getting lots of different kinds of
feedback from both sometimes verbally
sometimes watching them use it sometimes
you know when I showed that little demo
in the replay of a demo like the
introductory tour that's something very
easy for users to create so sometimes
you could replay what a user was doing
and see where some kinds of confusion
was happening or what but it hasn't been
sort of the real formal process though
the means very important this sort of
bitter design kind of getting things
back from users and one thing I should
say on a really topic is it's it's very
tricky this issue the extent to which
kids are really co designers because
that's one of the common common slogans
but when I early on was working with
kids many of their suggestions were kind
of missing the big point they would you
know that they would go on and on about
how oh well you should be able to walk
into the water and then there should be
sharks and you have to avoid the sharks
and that'd be kind of a fun thing but
it'd be kind of peripheral to the whole
point of mattoon talks really about or
something on the other hand they were
there were kind of computer science see
reasons why certain things you couldn't
put into a box you couldn't put bombs
into boxes for reasons that I could
explain from a computer science point of
view but when the kids would try to do
it and say why can't I put a bomb in a
box I could put you know birds i could
put numbers into boxes like the boxes
into boxes and when I realized I
couldn't give them an explanation at
their level I started realizing well
maybe you know they're right in the
computer
this kind of issue is kind of not really
so so that that was in a case where we r
you know the kids I think we're right
that should have been more uniform even
if there was a story from computer
sciences to that that Obama is really
more of expressing a praten it's not
really a an object in the sense the
other things are are such was a
different category and it shouldn't be
no but that wasn't the kind of way the
kids wanted to think about it there's a
value to accumulating way that people
say all that people that don't normally
do know don't come into your science
world how they interact and food kind of
ideas they have in their questions how
they move there's a huge value to that
yeah aside from what about the kids get
smarter or they actually make
interesting game you know right right
now you're right then and I should
before you do the question no no I'm
just going to show you something i think
i need the web the internet connection
but there was in web labs we really were
encouraging the kids to interact around
their tune talk programs and there was a
really nice example of that that uh i
have the link for but I again I don't
have the connection where this girl in
Portugal had made a robot that made this
kind of complex sequence of numbers and
she posted the first few numbers as a
challenge to other kids in the project
could you figure out what my robot was
and this two kids in Bulgaria picked it
up and they came up with completely
different robots than hers and then that
led to this really interesting
discussion between these three kids
about well how come our robots are doing
completely different things but they're
visiting the same numbers and and you
know will they always produce the same
numbers or is just the first ones that
they're seeing and and it really led to
a lot of nice back-and-forth and then
the one of the kids in Bulgaria said
well you know my robot with these other
inputs will produce this sequence could
your robot previously you know it was a
lot of back and forth that was quite
interesting and valuable and indication
these kids were really
excited about what they were doing in
the fact that they were not just
building these programs but that they
were in the social context of kind of
sharing and challenging each other was
really important on the other hand we
were divorced they crossed languages did
cross cultures but how does
communication between yeah yeah well so
so the I think it helped a lot the fact
that the tune type programs themselves
were just robots that were picking up
numbers doing multiplications additions
there wasn't even the issue of trying to
stand someone else's program where the
variable names are in another language
of the procedure names and then in terms
of the what they were saying on the webz
discussions I think the Bulgarian kids
actually did have an adult help them
with the English so they kind of had
some adult explaining Bulgarian what the
sport the portuguese girl actually
english was quite good at which made a
bunch of mistakes but it was still quite
clear what she was saying actually you
guys could probably look at it i can't
let's see I think I don't know see man
let's see it's probably not going to
worth doing this but because this is the
this is the ridiculo URL nevermind uh oh
but wait it's in my cash a little bit it
seems even though I'm not connected yeah
yeah because I looked at it the other
day so it's still well good anyways so
she says you know here's i created the
sequence of numbers my first my first
terms of the sequence hour and then she
didn't have the solution here later she
edited this later after a lot of
discussion and stuff and then this kid
nasco in he said well here's here's
here's my solution and and if you look
she her robot was working with three
different variables 22
times for whatever this one was working
with the liner of those there really are
quite different and then he posted back
you know and these things are things
which if you click on them well normally
he would be able to download it into to
talk and just become live real in tune
talk so you would see the the little
message the box that this robot work on
in Chris could try it out and go back
and forth so this was a very nice thread
but it to be honest wouldn't too many
Owen this kid was really proud of the
fact that he had a robot that was
reusing so fewer variables to produce
the same sequencing and he said he could
you know only have two holes in them
yeah so read i think was 14 and I think
nasco and Ivan were 10 or 11 but the
Bulgarian kids were the Portuguese kids
were in an ordinary school the Bulgarian
kids were I think in a kind of
after-school math club or something so
they were very math oriented but they
were younger
used or at problems using I know that
was the the really nice wasn't surprised
was that even this research that leonel
Morgado was doing in Portugal with with
four-year-olds showed that they were
really able to understand about robots
sent about birds and able to build
little programs and play with them and
seem to have an understanding of what
they did the the disappointing thing so
that was the really exciting thing was
the even very young kids were
understanding the computation model but
the disappointing thing was how how they
really couldn't be very task focused or
they didn't know how to really use what
they did to accomplish something so they
understood the basic building blocks but
if they had a little goal they didn't
know how to assemble the building blocks
to reach their goal so it was all very
kind of tinkering around and ever trying
to solve a problem or do any planning
the younger kids especially not a bit
there's also a huge body of work you
know interested is there a place I can
go look for a taxonomy of complex
composition or data about what sort of
compositions are in
no I've been wondering about that too
because there's been this theme as I
said you know running across much of you
know all these projects about about
composing things at this level and yet I
haven't found or people have been
pointed me to literature that this level
course it's very hard to find because
there's the there is a lot of stuff
about modular programming component babe
you know but but in this kind of sense
in which there they really are more like
current processes that you're adding and
that they're really well designed to fit
together so maybe I should I write the
paper like that myself is because we
know a lot about how to program I
suppose in a village if you dig like
program you're thinking how to compose
when you're not thinking like a program
something that doesn't sound right right
yeah so this point I'll bring a versa
that will fire off i'm going to look at
now one of the things I was just this
morning with the pop fly group here and
they're very much kind of dealing with
some of these same issues and also the
work on boku is Mary there's a i
mentioned that i think the playground
project was building both on tune
talking the other half of the project
was building on logo and they built
something that was kind of a simpler 2d
kind of analog to this work on boku
that's going on here and so so there is
some nice connections and i guess i
should be making clear to you know the i
kind of took examples from my own work
but there's you know the work from
berkeley and and heed assesses group
there's Alan Kay and the squeak project
there's you know MIT now with the
scratch and before that various logos
and then I am building on the
northwestern work so there is five or
six places in the world that are kind of
trying to do something like this but
they still like to talk without the
additional layers are kind of still
having this bottom-up kind of style yeah
when you compose behaviors going no no
yes so in the playground project this
did come up because kids were like
experimenting or fiddling around and
what we decided was sort of appropriate
was that if it's undetermined from the
computation model as to which process if
the order in which processes are run and
yet the orders going to make them a
difference in terms of how the system
behaves that to introduce randomness so
that you would sort of see visually that
you've got a conflict so if you took a
move left behavior and move right
behavior when this first came up in
playground you just got one of them
because one just happened to be run
second and dominated but but afterwards
you saw much more of like this
indecision in this object it would kind
of go left a few times and then the
schedule happened to change and go right
you know and kind of you saw some sense
visually that it was there was a
conflicting kind of behaviors here so
from a computer science point of view
there were there are these really tricky
questions about when there's some more
to dependency and how to deal with them
and with the behavior composer and Tim
talk one of the things that helps this
is by having a sort of parallel updates
so that within each phase of this thing
everybody's reading the same variables
and updating what they're going to be on
the next cycle so that that means that
doesn't really matter as much what order
they're going to run but you still could
get conflicts and one of the kind of
ironic things about all this conflict
stuff is that
this grew out of work that actually
deemed back there who's leaving was was
part of a cadet Xerox PARC on concurrent
constraint programming languages and
there we didn't have this idea of kind
of having them all kind of interacting
through this virtual space instead they
in to talk terms that was all
communicating and coordinating via birds
and nests and there you really can get
more control as the programmer as to
these issues about the ordering doesn't
matter because there's like something
equivalent like message queues all the
birds are being given messages they're
all flying in to the NASA they're
getting interleaved and then the some
other processes is taking them off so
that you could avoid many of the kinds
of classical problems with concurrency
about race conditions and and the like
because you've got a different
computation model so that was something
I was very excited about with turn talk
and it really was important for for some
projects that kids did especially when
they were exploring the convergence and
divergence of infinite sequences numbers
that those kind of communication ideas
that were came back to our work on a
programming language called Janus but
but for the most part the effort has
been ones whether you're simulating
creatures a little physical to entities
and one of the things is because you're
doing the sort of time slicing usually
the if the most common case is that
where the order of execution might make
a matter a difference in at the level of
these small kind of approximations are
thin slices so if you're turning and
going forward which one you do first if
you're a very small amounts each time is
is going to make a very small difference
to the behavior while
well if it's because you're you're doing
small amounts every 23 50th of a second
so frequently these these kinds of
ordering constraints were never even
noticed or visible but of course there's
a computer scientist in me says you know
we should be more consumed piece of
sloppier questions thank you very much
breakfast